[Music]
hi i'm paul from krapow london today
we'll be making the quintessential thai
street food moopi mooping is grilled
pork we do a slightly different variant
we get chunks of the meat and then slow
cook it in a pan waiting for those
juices to be released and caramelised
down at the end creates a lovely little
glaze on the outside of the cuts so
within my background i've got no
classical training as a chef it's very
much a case of passed on from my family
spending time with both my grandmothers
both of them were crazy in the kitchen
that sunday roast dinner is where kind
of my family would all come together and
get probably their vegetable fix for the
weekend that was a requirement because
during the week we'd be kind of asian
food mad my dad had his way he would
genuinely have curry breakfast lunch and
dinner there's always been a passion for
asian cooking we use pork collar in our
variation of anything in thailand you
would generally get very thin little
slivers that would just get sort of
shown the coals just cook them through
and thus keep it tender we actually
started with getting collar steaks
slicing them up individually skewering
them all and then cooking them like that
but we found that a cooking time was
taking forever in the pan it was taking
so much longer on the skewers and having
to delicately turn each skewer all the
time so we switched it around to just
doing the chunks just keep them moving
around in the pan i think the benefit of
cooking in the pan plays more to the
western taste in western culture
everybody wants a good chunk of meat
which they can chew on they can get
their teeth stuck into cooking this at
home the demand primarily comes from the
guys down at the rugby club there are a
number of people there that have gained
an addiction to this somewhat akin to
crack so yeah we have to every now and
again cook up big batches and take that
up to the rugby club for a bit of a post
match
[Music]
that's moving
[Music]
you